if it wasn't for soccer I don't think I  want to play it in the NBA my first word  was goal it just took me 18 years in  professional basketball to get back to  it  following my favorite teams ritual  that's an obsession I can't get enough  and I know that's the same for millions  of people around the world and now I  have an opportunity to share my love of  the game as a part of the be our  football team bringing to you the best  competition is in soccer some of the  best athletes and biggest personalities  in the world all fighting it out for one  winner every year if it's in your blood  it's in your blood and you can't live  without it  [Music]  you  [Applause]